もし男いうだと思って入ってた温泉が時間
で女に変わるタイプの汚点で入ってるうち
に女えになっちゃってまだいるのに美女が
さっさん排出へ来たら同数の時0
夢でこれもドラマっぽく味見と型番にある
と思うんですけど男縁っていうか入って
ますとああっ入って言ったらもう時間で女
ようになってて広いみたいな音なのかが
ぞろぞろぞろぞろ入ってきて絶体絶命の大
ピンチの主人公みたいなパターンがあると
思いますそれやります仕掛けられる奴がが
売られますし今回はそんな夢のような
ドッキリをやってみたいと思います今回で
こんな僕がかけたバカなような企画を実現
させていただいたのは気軽に身近に通える
温泉宿で有名な伊東園ホテルずさんの全面
協力のもと
今回このドッキリをしていきたいと思い
ます本当にご協力ありがとうございます
どうやると思う人はいろんなパターンが
想定されると思うんですよ隠れて守護ス
タイプか知らせんでで決まって売ってるべ
パターンが結構いろんなパターンがあると
思いますけども今回も様々なターゲット
準備したのでぜひ日アクションを楽しんで
いきましょうという意味で今回協力して
くださる女性の方頭がいらっしゃいまし
たらどうぞ
ああああああ
みんな綺麗ですね
今日はよろしくお願いしますよくある
アニメとかとの間であるんですけども温泉
って男糸御礼が切り替わる時間ってあるん
ですよね男にで最初はぁゲットが温泉に
入ってて気づいたら時間が切り替わって
言って bon 年になって
流れ
[音楽]
me
1回ちょっとボケで行って見てもらっても
いいですか
[笑い]
思うっていうかねぇ勝敗なよろしくお願い
ますねああああああああ
僕にやっていこうと思いますうえっ
えっと指でまずは私肇社長が自ら
デモンストレーションでは行っていきたい
とおもいますアンケ4やりたいわけであり
ませんやはりあの実際にやってみないと
うまくいったどうかわからないので余裕を
もって
ありますとても広い温泉で感動しました私
ていません
こんなにバスターズ場合ファイルに良く
ないんですけれどもちょっと
youtube の規約的にいろいろ見え
てはいけないことが多いのでパスターを
消せ下には ana ちゃんと服を着て
入っておりますも安心ください
も強かったんですよ
ポジターゲットが最高の初めてでポン日に
してる間にいい
開きましてきましたきましたね
嘘軍団がやってきました
立ってターゲットボトムこういうがカール
のんですねやばいやばいってまぁこれは誰
だねここはですけども
隠れなきゃと思っていてくれます
どんどん迫ってくる以上組んだんだ
私はドイツあの近くになるように柱の歌と
かによってきたっ
どう見ても見えていますサービズが温泉に
入ってきました
かなり距離の近いです道を見ても私ばれて
おります
不動温泉かなり広いのでその資格がないと
言うとも閣僚がないのでどのターゲットも
を育てばレールはずです
おおおおおお
いいいいねぇ
近い近いっていいいいねぇ
すごい緊張しますねバレルとも大変です
から本当は
さあ
いつバレるに積まれると恐怖に怯えながら
着れています
あっ
ああああああ
あー水でバシャバシャ本当は温泉でこう
いうの良くないんですけども今回撮影の為
行っておりますあの日に参詣して音声子は
マネしないでくださいわー
あのすごいあの申し訳ない気持ちになり
ました
ん
モーセが1人目がきます
[音楽]
goo
par
その際胸部の発疹は車
ああああああ
さあプールで最初のターゲットサーべてを
状態になった後輩の一人です
彼は今年童貞を卒業したんですけれども今
形4程度あの向きってないので結構女性等
の送ろうとかという状況になるとかなり
緊張しちゃうのかなという気がしており
ます
技温泉の広さに驚くターゲット
あった本当に普通も旺盛ファイルだけの
気持ちんですよね
あれどまずは宇津井
僕のお二人だけで入っていきます
マイケルさトイレ行ってくるわわもうの僕
だけ抜け出すという言葉です遊びました
ごめんなさい
ああああああ
ええええええ
t
[音楽]
wh
rar
car
rarさあ女ように切り替わってしまい
ましたさあゲットはどうしてしまうのか今
だ力持つよさそうにしているかもう大成長
には女性た女性がば
今
[音楽]
横線の中に入ったあー
すごいている舗道
わーいずっと性が出てきました
童貞のサワー
あまた試験の体を洗って言う女性たちこの
隙にからパターン
で周りをキョロキョロ深夜たせが動かない
のかなぜかたくなるなぜまた2女の母
このうちに出ればいいのになぜ彼を作ると
か
あー晴れて正たか
are you do
すぐ手を通し苗童貞のままで
サー女性たちに怒りの声がは性がありして
られるがそれが
ケンシロウな感じで
そんな時間当ててない感じだしながらもう
しっかりと
よそれでアスタリアぬ
怖がられながら変え方を変えると言われ
てっ
退出しました
[音楽]
dare
ん
それを床にが本体に革靴スキルでさぁ
いや動けなかっただ
えええ
えええええええ
uaran
[音楽]
me
goo
car
[音楽]
たええええええ
さあ人生すでにこのプロは女になってい
ます何も知らないでしょうね彼はもちろん
佐藤サー女性たちが今
一つんでした
mar
上がってませんお台場でことは
月から女性たちも足を進める
あなたを
さんはで白人てる間に彼はたチャーリー
頑張って抜いてだけしてくれてます
ああああああ
ranrar
て取った
[拍手]
ベンツ両者言ってることがあっております
ここはおとなしく出て行くターゲット意外
と律儀だせっねっ
失礼しますと言いながらあって曲げられる
良いキャッチ
何抜いてるなぁバー
ん
me
さぁ次のターゲットはまた像です彼は
スティーブな男の一人がこの状況で何を
思いどう動くのか見どころです
ああああああ
いいしています
th
marmeさあまたぞ浮いている時間は
内臓もそこは既に女湯だ魔の手が忍び寄っ
ているさ調整等が突入しました
入ってしまいましたねはいいらっしゃいま
気づいたん
[音楽]
お土産だ土産だ正直な反応は悪くないさあ
どうするしっかりとまずは温泉の中を動く
足は5強だ遠い土足左下の方へ北館
なるほどまずは死角になるように隠れると
いい花メス
かなりコーナー部分に隠れたのでなかなか
気づかれにくい場所だと思われますいい
判断ですね
あとタオルをタオルをおおなんか広げて
いる
ちょっとしてみたからサー女性たちが
シャワーで体を洗い終わり今温泉に入水
喘ぎ始めています
あれはいったいどう勢力だろうかとおっと
かグリル壁と一体化しよちょっと見てる
その命はなんだ僕ない無駄
イベントばれていないいい作成なる
でしょうかこれは
音なんでそのちょっとだけ顔出すんだ
ブーブーいるし合っ女性をしっかりと捉え
ている
ブービーたいという男の執念を感じられ
ます貯留のではないでしょうか近寄るとず
実に行きます
で使います
やっぱりなこれ
re
ほん
[音楽]
t子 oh
boo
[拍手]
ああああああ
ん
だけどまとうさんえっ男いうがちょっと
時間で切り替わって女になってるみたいな
うわぁ
そんな版ですねあのすごいながとっさに
待ったぞはたんだかクリアとじゃなかった
間で etoile さんを阻まれたくな
いって気を付けてしまったらバレたくなく
てちょっとでもあそこに言いたかったん
さぁ次のターゲットは傭兵先生むっつり
スケベで有名です
彼もなかなか
スケベなのでちょっと頭するのですが気に
なるところです
さあもうすでにそこは完全に女ようです
ハリド腰に巻いてなぜ改造してますね浅井
は女性たちが入りました
まずはその声を聞いて何を思う
三宅だ髪の毛がない方でこう触るん
持った
ちょっと困っているようですね
かなり困って利用だが表情顔に気持ちが
隠せないに挙げているその中爽やかだ
女性食べるさはで体を洗っています名前だ
彼はどうするのか
まだそう言い続けることだった動いだああ
とりあえず
バレないように移動するということか
しっかりとそのアースを進めております
女性の強体を洗い終わって今入手しようと
いうところですあれ洋ゲーての姿がない
どこ行ったらでしょうかこれでどこ行っ
たらそのスライドねーぞ
加盟 later
柱の隙間で隠れていたそれをすごいバレ
にくいところだ
当たり前だろです
あの子らの隙間に隠れていますそこは失格
ですね今の所はれていませんが
間に当たり前に花のようにそこで歌って
いる傭兵先生すごい顔をこする気合いを
入れ直したばいばーぐだ支持しよう
温度管理が下手側の資格です
いやらしい子いいところ遊びましたねそこ
はもバレない気がします
持ったが溢れるあの別の音声も見に行こう
という感じでちょっと周りをうろついてい
ますね
ああもう移動してますね客が生活が心臓
考えています
今度もう何か女性が裏に回り込もうとして
いる
かわいい
マーケットではもうこれはれるのではない
かこれ
ああああああ
[拍手]
[音楽]
ブーブー
jr 先生ゲームしてる間に俺だけ
てきた瞬間マリが女性に書く生まれている
という謎のシチュエーションになっており
ますさあ今外れ社長 vs 大地の潜水
ゲームが始まろうとしています
需要がないことはわかっておりますが
あの俺だけすぐ開けるにできるんでさぁ
経営の
褒めたそしてこの間にポピュラー系さあ
飛ん抜けて増税等が乳清すぐにターゲット
男ります
大地くん今年一年ありがとう君には感謝し
ています
囲まれる第二まだ何も知らない人だけ成績
をせよ
今出るいます
あっはっはー
あっはぁ
[音楽]
うぉっ
はああああああ